Well, very ready knowing him, as you can see on a they've today announced the,
the Nobel prize for physics. So in a nutshell, it's it's concert,
black holes is the only way I could describe it.
The wording of the citation is kind of interesting. So let me just read it out.
It says the Nobel prize in physics 2020, it was divided one half audit.
Roger Penrose for the discovery that black hole formation is a robust prediction
of the general theory of relativity,
the other half jointly to Reinhardt Gainesville.
And Andrea gets for the discovery of a supermassive compact object at the center
of our galaxy.
And you'll notice it sort of skates round saying anything there being about
there being a massive black hole at the center of our galaxy,
because technically no one has really proved that that's what it is. It's just,
you know,
no one can think of anything else that it could possibly be at this point.
So storm, is there going to be looking at the black hole sense of our galaxy,
basically what they, they,
they were looking at this managed to establish that there was a really compact
object there, 4 million solar masses in basically a region,
the size of our solar system, or even less, and, you know, the remarkable,
astronomical observations.
But the guy I want to talk about is the other half of the prize,
which is asked Roger Penrose, cause I'm a theorist and he's a theorist, um,
and services. We share love interests, um,
and the work that he did and the reason that, uh,
Penrose got the prize and it was really,
he basically sort of lent taught something about the structure of protocols and
what lurks inside of and what lurks inside a black hole.
It's this dreaded singularity. This is this region of sort of, eh,
infinitely strong gravitational field, infinite space-time curvature,
that horrible word, infinity that basically these,
this horrible monster at the center of a black hole exists. So I would say it's,
you know,
that 1965 pay for that remarkable pay for which showed that these singularities
offer real. I didn't really shut the world of physics.
Everybody was stoned by it.
No one saw it because they thought these similarities were just, uh, an office,
lots of symmetry.
They didn't think they were real Henry shared that they were real general.
Relativity, Germany really did predict them. And,
and then Hawking then took that on. And I worked at Penrose as well,
and they showed that you could get these similarities, you know, in a,
sort of at the big bang of the start of the universe,
or maybe at the end of the university,
it wasn't just inside black holes and the whole story sort of,
sort of blossomed into something. And, and the other thing it tells you,
these similarities tell you is that is the general relativity is not a complete
theory because it can't describe those singularities it's
outside, even though, even though predicts, they exist.
And Penrose showed us that, you know,
you follow your nose and follow general relativity,
you're going to end up with this place with these strata.
Singularities actually, it can't really describe it.
And that's why we know we need more than general relativity. We need, uh,
a quantum theory of gravity, whatever that might be string theory or whatever.
So it also tells it also sort of spelled the demise of general relativity.
We know it's not the full story.
It's just one of the other wonderful things about what Penrose did.
This is a great piece of it because a fibrous piece of back, as I said,
it's probably the most important, uh, paper in, in, in gravity,
between Einstein's original papers and his in 1965. But,
but you don't really see Nobel prizes in the past given for these kinds of
theory papers. Um, now no one's actually gone into a black hole,
has spotted a singularity that hasn't happened,
and yet they've given him this prize.
And I think it marks a bit of a change for, um,
for theorists and potential Nobel prize winners. And I think it's a great thing.
I absolutely applaud it so long to make this continue. And maybe it's, uh,
once again, uh,
so Roger is going to be a bit of a trailblazer for everybody else.
Well,
it's really all about showing that there's a very massive object at the center
of the galaxy and in principle showing, measuring the mass of something,
showing that there is a massive object somewhere is reasonably straightforward
in astronomy. In that, for example,
we know that the sun's at the center of the solar system, not just because,
you know, it glows in the sky,
but actually because it holds all the planets in orbit around it.
And so actually even if the sun weren't giving out any light at all,
we'd be able to say there's a massive object in the center of the solar system.
And actually we'd even be able to say what its mass was just by studying the
orbit of the earth and the other planets around it. So in principle,
you can sort of do that,
make that kind of measurement for anything which is gravitation you bound
together. And in essence,
that's what they've done for the center of the Milky way.
In that they'd been looking at the stars orbiting around the center of the Milky
way and showing that the orbits they're following imply that there's a very
massive object at the center of the Milky way.
It sounds very simple the way I say it there. Um, of course in practice,
it's a huge amount, more complicated and in part that's because,
so it's part in part is because you're looking at something which is pretty
small in that the whole of the region that they're looking at,
where those things are all orbiting around a rule within an arc second or so.
And that's the scale on which if you just take a picture of a star, uh,
with the telescope from the ground,
typically the atmosphere blurs out the image to about an arc second.
So actually all those stars packed in with those central field.
Arcseconds if you just took a naive picture of the center of the galaxy with the
telescope,
they will be blurred together and you wouldn't actually be able to see anything
at all and follow their emotion.
The other complication is that the center of the Milky way is a very difficult
place to see because between us and the center of the galaxy,
there's a huge amount of Merck. This, this,
this stuff that astronomy is referred to as dust,
it's sort of this city smoky material,
which obscures the view of the center of the galaxy,
which essentially means that very little of the light coming from the center of
the galaxy gets to us. If you look in the optical part of the spectrum,
it's something like, you know,
one photon in 10 billion emitted near the center of the galaxy actually gets to
it. So there's no chance of actually seeing it.
The solution to both of these problems actually came along sort of in the 1990s
when, um, astronomers started first making images,
decent images in the infrared part of the spectrum.
So it sort of technology driven that we started getting the,
the detectors that allow us to make images, uh,
in the infrared part of the spectrum,
where previously we'd really only been able to make optical images.
And the infrared has two big advantages. Firstly, that,
that Merck is more or less transparent.
So instead of sort of one photon in 10 billion getting through it's something
like one photon in five gets through.
So there's still a fair amount of it gets obscured by the dust between us and
the center of the galaxy, but actually enough gets through that.
You can start making images.
The other big advantage of the infrared is it's more straightforward to take out
those blurring effects of the atmosphere to sharpen up the images.
And so a lot of the,
the breakthroughs in this area I've come because adaptive optics,
these techniques that astronomers use to take out the blurring effects of the
atmosphere work well in the infrared part of the spectrum.
So they've really been able to sharpen up those images.
So instead of seeing those 20 or 30 stars near the center of the galaxy,
all blurred together into a single splodge,
they really can make pictures of the individual stars and that has enabled them
to monitor those stars and actually literally see them orbiting around the
center of the Milky way, apparently around nothing.
There's nothing very much there. Well, it's a radio source there.
So there's something there that we thought was a bit suspicious and that's
something that gives out radio waves. Um, but there's not, there's no,
there's no obvious star there or anything bright there. Um,
and these stars near the center of the galaxy are all following these nice
elliptical orbits, just like the planets around the sun,
whizzing around something which doesn't appear to be there.
And now they've been able to observe them for long enough that some of those
stars they've actually seen them go round. They're complete elliptical orbits.
Now that gives you a very strong constraint on, okay, I can actually measure,
I know what the pull of gravity has to be to be making things orbit around the
center of the galaxy at that speed.
And that's how they come up with this number of a super massive object in that
central region of the Milky way of a few million times, the mass of the sun.
So it's called a singularity,
the black hole singularity where Penrose entered the game.
Was he writing this paper? And in, uh, in 1965,
which basically shocked the world of physics.
And basically what Penrose showed was that this thing already was liking was
there, okay. That it was predicted by general relativity.
So what happened previously is people like Oppenheimer and Schneider had been
looking at things like sort of collapsing, uh, you know,
it's fairly symmetric collapsing,
sort of clouds of dust and shells and things like that.
And in these very symmetric scenarios,
they were seeing it as thought those symmetric sort of distributions of matter
collapsed in that indeed you would fall a black hole and at the center of that
black hole would be one of these dreaded singularities and people were like,
all right, we're not taking that seriously.
That's just because you were considering a situation with an awful lot of
symmetry. That's the only reason that read singularity, that weird infinity,
that madness is there,
but what Penrose showed was it wasn't really at a counter this symmetry,
it would always be there. Okay. Did,
this was really an artifact of general relativity that black holes do these
similarities. Okay.
He proved the singularity theorems and it was much more general.
It didn't require symmetry. It was extremely general statement.
All you had to say was basically as long as I have effectively positive energy,
if I'm thinking about matter, that's made of a positive energy,
then I'm guaranteed, then it collapses form black hole.
I'm guaranteed to get one of these singularities, which is basically,
it's just an end of space or an end of time.
It's one of those things that kind of crept up on the field in that, you know,
back in the 1960s, people started discovering these things called quasars,
which were these incredibly bright, distant objects,
which were varying on timescales of days or at least, you know,
weeks and months as well. Um, which tells you to have to be very small, right,
for something to very, very quickly, you know,
if you actually had a whole galaxies worth of stars,
even if you found some way of switching them all off and on,
because of the amount of time it takes light to travel just from one side of the
galaxy to the other,
you wouldn't see the whole thing switching on and off very quickly.
So when you see something varying on timescales of say a few months that tells
you, it can only be a few light months across.
So these quasars were varying on very short timescales,
which told you they were very small and they were also incredibly bright.
And this combination of things, people were costing around trying to figure out,
could they be supermassive stars or various other ideas were thrown around.
But the, the idea that one out is that had to be a very,
very massive object and material was falling into it.
And you were seeing the kind of the energy that was liberated as the material
fell into it.
And that would both give you a lot of energy because if the thing's very
compact, the polar gravity is very strong.
So the stuff falls in extremely fast and you have a lot of energy,
but it's all in a very small region. And so it varies very quickly. So that was,
you know, as I say, back in the 1960s, 19, early 1970s,
people were starting to think about it in the 1970s,
this radio source at the center of the Milky way, Sagittarius a star,
which is where this black hole is located, was found.
And that got people thinking, well,
maybe there's one in the middle of the Milky way as well.
With the advent of the Hubble space telescope in the 1990s,
we were for the first time able to actually start, um,
resolving regions, close enough to the center of other galaxies to see actually,
yes, stars are whizzing around extremely fast there as well.
So it's one of those things that kind of crept up on us a bit at the time. Um,
but this is sort of, you know, this is the, the, the,
the best measurement we have the ultimate measurement and actually at some
level, you know, knowing it's there in our own galaxy tells us quite, you know,
quite how commonplace is, is that even an ordinary galaxy,
like ours has a massive black hole in the middle of it.
What did Penrose Shalisha? He showed that,
that the space-time wasn't complete inside the black hole and what he shared was
it wasn't
[inaudible] GD ethics or the sort of shortest parts in space time that a puffs
that a particle will take. If it's, if it's not accelerating through space type,
it'll follow a shortest path. Now, shearing,
you are a mortar and you can in principle live through,
as long as time could exist, you would just follow Judy's six forever. Okay.
You would just go on and on and on and on and on. Right.
What Penrose showed was if you fall into a black hole and you follow one of
these GDD things, eventually the GDC itself will grind to a halt.
I think about what that really means.
That means there's an end to either time or space is actually an
end to timeless space. So even though you might think you're immortal,
nothing can destroy you well, the end of time can destroy you.
So if you're falling into one of these black holes,
you're falling one of these GDS X, depending on the nature of the GDS,
you will start to feel very strong gravitational fields.
You'll start to feel yourself being ripped apart by the tides of gravity,
literally, you know, the atoms in your body being torn apart. And then,
you know, as you sort of beg for mercy, you know,
even if you're capable of backing,
because you're asked as a veto to pose you beg for mercy, what you'll find is,
is that you'll be given that messy because time itself or possibly space,
but in the case of, um, depends on the nature of the black hole,
but time itself will end. Okay. So even though you think you're a immortal,
well, it doesn't matter because there is no more time, time itself stops.
And that's what Penrose showed that these things are really lurking there inside
black holes.
Well,
we talked about these stars orbiting around very close to the center of the
Milky way. They're still, you know, so there's one particular star S two,
which is the one that's gone closest to the center.
And that's one that they've now followed around a full orbit. And in fact,
he got so close. You remember, if you think about elliptical orbits, uh,
like comments in the solar system, for example,
when they're kind of in their outskirts. So their orbits,
they travel very slowly and then they whizzed past the sun and then back out
again, it's just the same story here. The stars hang around.
And then when they're close to the black hole,
they whiz past it and then slow down when they're traveling away from it.
The one that went closest to the, um,
to the black hole at the center of the Milky way was traveling at about two and
a half percent of the speed of light.
So it was actually a decent fraction of the speed of light and God sufficiently
coasts that there's all sorts of, interesting things you can do with it.
For example,
it was sufficiently close to the black hole that the light escaping from it not
only had to escape from the star,
but had to escape from the gravitational field of the black hole as well.
And so they were able to measure that gravitational red shift,
the energy that the light lost as it was escaping from the region of the black
hole. But even in these cases, we're still, you know, we're still the distance.
I think it was a hundred or so astronomical units from the,
the putative black hole in the center of the Milky way. Um,
so sort of a hundred times the distance of the earth to the sun,
which is about a thousand or so times this thing called the short shield radius,
which at some level is sort of the size of the black hole.
It's that point of no return where even light can't escape.
So the sort of the size of the black hole was a thousand times smaller than the
scale that this star was probing. So we can't actually say,
we can say within a thousand times the size of a black hole as the mass of a
black hole, but for it to actually be definitely a black hole,
we have to be able to say, you know, within one times the,
of the black hole versus that much mess, but actually we can only say it's,
within a thousand times that region,
there is nothing else that anyone could think of that would pack that much mass
into that smaller region that wasn't a black hole,
but that's why they sort of hedge their bets that tiny bit in the citation by
just saying this, this, the huge amount of mass in this very small region,
rather than saying there is a black hole left. I mean, the mass of the,
of whatever is there is incredibly accurately determined.
I'd have to look up the number now, but it says,
I think the best measurement of it is it's 4.15 plus or minus
0.01 million solar masses.
So that's an incredibly, you know, by astronomical standards,
usually in astronomy, we're happy if we get something within a factor of two,
right? So actually, you know,
measuring something to that level of precision is incredible that they know very
accurately how much master is there.
They just don't know for sure that it's all compressed within a region,
small enough that it has to be a black hole. Um, so as I say,
almost certainly is there's nothing else that anyone could think of that would
explain it. Um, but they haven't in that sense,
seen a black hole in the same way that for example,
the event horizon telescope was able to actually image very close to a black
hole itself. They're actually looking at a slightly larger region, um,
which is telling you how much mass is there. And it's all very concentrated,
but it doesn't in itself tell you for certain that there's a black hole there.
They were very much in competition with each other.
So there were two groups in the world. So gets working at UCLA,
UCLA in California, was using the Keck telescopes in Hawaii.
And Gainesville was working in Germany and using the European Southern
observatory telescopes in Chile. Um,
so they really were sort of in competition and it's one of those sort of healthy
competitions. I don't think it was, you know, it wasn't that they weren't, uh,
um, unpleasant towards each other. It's just one of those things.
There was an exciting thing that sort of occurred to both of them at the same
time. They both started working on it at this more or less the same time. Um,
and they've sort of both been competing to get the results out,
which is both healthy and that it's sort of competition.
It drives us on to do things better. Um,
but also it's sort of healthy to have that cross-check because if it was only
one person in the world was claiming they'd found something, you know,
you always think, you know,
could they possibly have made a mistake somewhere along the line? Um,
so it's good to have two completely different groups using different
instrumentation and potentially different techniques for analyzing their data.
And so on both arriving at essentially the same conclusion.
We have sort of a one corner of the Penrose Institute and we had the first and
the sort of ignore inaugural workshop at the Penrose Institute took place right
here in Nottingham a couple of years ago.
And he was here for extended periods and drank a cup of coffee in the,
in the library there and taught for a long time about physics.
He also gave us some lectures, which were fabulous. And, and,
and the remarkable thing about it was this is a guy who's well into his eighties
and these lectures were going on for like two hours and his stomach was
astonishing. I first met him sort of, well, it's probably about 10,
15 years ago now. And, uh, I was a postdoc in Oxford and he was,
he was actually retired by that point. Uh, but the, this,
this idea he'd had in, in a sort of late sixties,
early seventies twisters suddenly came back into fashion and he came out of
retirement to give us all, some lectures on it. And, uh, well,
our remember about those lectures was, I mean, never five minutes,
but what I remember most about them was how good he was at drawing pictures.
He would draw these pictures in the latches. So they were just also,
it's like what Greg is. He's, he's, he's not just a great mathematician.
And a great physics is greater, is a great artist as well. So it saves cells.
That was one thing that stuck in my mind of, uh, of, uh,
early days of meeting Roger Penrose.
But obviously he's a legend to physics and maths, and, um,
it's been a privilege to have a minimal and not skim.
And it's great that he's won the Nobel prize.
That poses a few problems. I'm sure you can imagine.
One of them is the fact that as you tip the mirror through the night to look at
different angles of the sky,
gravity starts to affect the mirror and deformed ever so slightly.
So what you do is you have something called active optics, which are,
see all those little pistons there.
There's 150 actuators,
basically little pistons that can push and pull.